retired four-star navy admiral william
mcraven is the man who oversaw the raid
that ended with the death of osama bin
laden we all remember that his 37-year
military career included time as a navy
seal and commander of an all u.s special
operations forces his latest role though
listen to this
is children's author i love this it's
called make your bed with skipper the
seal it's based on mcraven's
best-selling book for adults that was
called make your bed this new book
teaches kids about perseverance and
dealing with failure some very lucky
kids at the hoboken public library in
new jersey got to hear the admiral
himself read the book
oh he's sitting down so this is make
your bed
with skipper
the seal
skipper the seal
lived in the sea
he was smart
and strong
and tough as could be skipper joined the
navy to be the best
to grow through training
hard and rough to find out if he was
good enough
to be a navy seal
skipper started each day
by making his bed
take a little pride his instructor said
this teaches the value of doing things
right
it will help you later
as you go through life
you see there he is there's skipper
there were other seals
in skipper's class
big ones little ones
slow and fast
but their size didn't matter
nor did their speed
all that mattered
was their will
to succeed
navy seal training was tough as could be
but skipper and his friends were tougher
you see
they never once thought to ring the bell
to quit on their team when things didn't
go well
they'd taken seal lessons straight to
the heart
be proud
be brave be hopeful be smart
and skipper he'd proven he had the right
stuff
finally he knew
he was good enough
to be a navy seal
tada i wish we had time to read the
whole book it's so good admiral mcraven
joins us now good to see you admiral
mcgregor
now last time we last time i saw you we
were both awaiting the birth of our
first grandchild mine has arrived luke
lynn miller has arrived yours william
thomas mcraven has arrived how old is he
five weeks he's five weeks so if you
hadn't had him would you have written
this book did you write it with him in
mind or were you always planning to
write a children well i wasn't always
planning to write a book but you know as
a young parent i love to read to my kids
as i think all parents do yes
you want to spend time with them you
want to kind of teach them
good values good lessons which i hope
the book does
so i had intended to write the book but
the first reading
went to william thomas i was wondering
if he got a chance to hear you but
we don't have time to read the whole
book but i just have to point this out
because i love this page hard work is
important the instructor said and most
days your hard work will get you ahead
here's the best part but sometimes in
life things just aren't fair smile don't
complain it won't lead anywhere i'm
thinking now this book is for people
four to eight but honestly you can pass
this to a couple of adults i know i
think so it's uh of course it's based on
the original book make your bed so some
of those lessons were were in make your
bed we i've kind of kidified them a
little bit but uh but sure kids and
adults all need to realize that
sometimes life's not fair you got to
kind of smile through it and move on so
speaking of the the original book and
now this new edition you once told our
david martin that you thought that you
were put on this planet to bring justice
to bin laden
but then in fact on deeper reflection
you think that these lessons and these
books are in fact your larger purpose
yeah why do you think this is so
important to you well the fact the
matter is the the message of make your
bet and hopefully the message of make
your bed with skipper the seal
really seemed to resonate uh you know
hundreds of millions of people have
viewed the commencement address of uh
and a couple million have bought the
book and i get uh you know emails every
week from people saying that the lessons
really helped them through the tough
moments in life and while i'm incredibly
proud of the work that the guys did in
getting bin laden
i actually think that the the make your
bed speech and the books have
you know gotten to more people and maybe
have done uh a lot of good might change
the world even more maybe so now
speaking of one of those lessons in here
um
skipper and the instructor tells us to
stand up to sharks and bullies in the
sea
how do you hope that translates to life
well you know the fact of the matter is
uh there are sharks everywhere the
bullies everywhere they're going to be
bullies on the playground with the kids
there are bullies in the office space
there are bullies in the boardroom and
you know kids need to learn at a young
age that uh and and you know i don't
know what that age is the parents can
kind of help figure that out but you
kind of have to stand up for what you
think is right yeah and you have to
stand up to the bullies on the
playground you know in the boardroom
wherever those bullies might be and if
you learn that lesson young hopefully
it'll follow you through the rest of
your life but you said the bully's
retreat and i went i don't know admiral
i've had a couple of bullies they did
not retreat yeah but you know what i
found and i you know in the first book i
talked about saddam hussein yes and when
we captured saddam hussein you know he
was pompous he was arrogant uh but very
quickly he just became a pathetic old
man because we kind of stood up to
saddam hussein you know in in this book
of course i'm i'm doing the kind of
shark analogy and it was it was
interesting at the hoboken library when
i showed the kids the pictures of the
shark they all did the shark thing yeah
so they get it they get it at a young
age the book has 10 lessons in it for
young readers the one that gail
referenced uh about life being not fair
is one of those lessons that i think is
the biggest complaint i get as a parent
right but that's not fair
so what do you think all parents get
that yeah you get it right so what's the
response
yeah well i mean the response is i'm
sorry sometimes life isn't fair and
again i think you want to teach your
your children as young as uh as they can
when that lesson is appropriate that
that hey sometimes it's just not fair
you really do have to kind of smile and
learn to work through the unfairness
yeah because you're going to encounter
unfairness for the rest of your life
the simplicity bill of making your bad
because i listen i don't do that
um i know and i i really and i i regret
it
literally hello my name is gayle yeah
literally and so i i regret that that's
not a lesson that i taught my children
why is that such an important lesson to
teach well i do think it's about kind of
starting your day off with a little
something to come something you take a
little pride in yes yeah and making your
bed is an easy thing to do i know and
when you do that then it it helps with
the next task and the next thing you got
it yeah awesome boo i don't make my bed
because there's still a person in it in
the morning when i leave admiral william
mcraven thank you very much make your
bed with super with skipper the seal
rather con sale right now we'll be right
back thanks very much beautiful
illustrations too